hi I'm Erik Bosse and this Avengers end
game gets closer and closer a guy can
only rewatch the in-game trailer so many
times to wring it out for missed clues
but there might be one more that we all
somehow overlooked one that might hinted
gamora's return an end game I know
whether it's Loki actually masquerading
as Bruce Banner vision uploading to the
cloud or Heimdall having a twin brother
we never knew about we will do
everything we can to explain the crazy
ways the characters that we saw died
didn't actually die c4s denial is the
only stage of grief spoiler warning case
any of these theories into being right
in everyone your life and to get us
started much of this gomorrah
speculation actually came from a couple
social media posts so that means we're
in for another new rock star
okay so recently it's always held on
that who plays Gamora of course posted a
seemingly random Instagram video of her
getting taken out of her green makeup
she included in the caption at Avengers
hmm so why would she be posting this
video in January 2019 when the latest
she would have shot a scene in makeup as
Gamora would have been in late 2017 or
early 2018 as production was winding
down for infinity war a movie in which
by way her character died could at
Avengers mean she could have been
shooting reshoots for Avengers in-game
and Gamora could return in this next
movie now I'm sure you're saying it's
also possible this is simply an old
video TVT to stuff that she was doing a
year ago maybe but on the same day as
this video went up a couple hours later
Karen Gillan who plays gamora's sister
nebula tweeted this washing the blue
from under my fingernails one more time
hashtag in-game the timing here is
suspect the fact that they both within a
few hours of each other posted similar
social media posts about being done with
their characters makeup processes and
Gillan's on the net said it was in game
related implies that there will be some
seen the movie with both nebula and
Gamora reunited perhaps the flashback
showing the two children of Thanos is
early days with a mad Titan or maybe the
result of one of these other crazy
timeline meddling theories that brought
up traveling back in time to when Gamora
was still alive or splitting into a
parallel timeline where Gamora is still
alive we're ghosts but that brings us to
this one miserable shot in the Avengers
end game trailer come
not halfway through when nebula appears
on the guardianship the benitar to
comfort Tony Stark now I had this
question the trailer first came out but
I didn't think much of it so I kind of
left it out that is until several of you
have been tweeting me endlessly asking
about it so a number of people out there
are saying this close-up ain't nebulas
hand it's gomorrah's hand and that might
not even be Tony Stark
remember this of what your good
instincts may be telling you about this
let's talk about it so sure comforting
anyone is definitely a weird thing for
nebula to do from what we see and she
has one emotion vengeful rage the last
time she used her hand to express an
emotion it was to get the big fu to
Gamora in the first guardians performing
to cut off ronan than to take her
sister's which actually might be part of
the conspiracy thinking with nebula in
the endgame trailer shouldn't her hand
be mechanical no that was her left hand
her right hand the one on the shoulder
here has appeared to be blue fleshed in
the past some folks have been looking at
the sleeve or the wristband at the base
of this hand saying it looks very
similar to gamora's wristband and
another pictures of Gamora you can see
something going across her palm but and
other pictures of nebula you can see
that she also has that over her right
hand
so while Gamora may reappear an Avengers
in-game in some form I do not think that
we're looking at her here on the Benatar
this is probably nebula of course that
does still leave the question open of
Hal Gamora will appear an endgame
if Gamora does appear I'm thinking her
presence will be key to bringing Panos
down since sacrificing her was the thing
that hurt Thanos the most the moment he
snapped his fingers whom did he see
young Gamora he tells her he gave up
everything so maybe the end game will
feature a grown up Gamora as some
ghostly presence in the soul stone
haunting Thanos and realizing his snap
was a mistake yep good good good ghost
maybe that ghostly presence will connect
with nebula in a scene that fractured
relationship between these two was still
loosened and I just don't think Marvel
will leave it that way I would say they
could patch things up in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 but looking at him at
gilens tweet she did say one more time
so nebula may not make it out of endgame
alive either
this might be the sisters last chance to
make things right now I want to talk
about the other interesting element in
this close-up over on the right
but first thanks to our sponsor
Skillshare for helping us make this
video skill series an online learning
community with more than
25,000 classes the design business
technology and more its premium
membership gives you unlimited access so
you can join the classes and communities
that are just right for you and your new
year goals whether you want to fuel your
curiosity creativity or even career
skill share is the perfect place to keep
you learning and thriving in 2019 for me
when I'm breaking down subtle film
details movie trailers it helps to be a
filmmaker myself you know someone who
has to structure my own stories and
think about what kind of scenes would be
the most somatically plausible so I'm
taking this Skillshare course DIY
cinematography make your own video look
like a movie with Ryan booth and I'm
learning a lot of stuff about how to
conceive a shot cinematically and think
in terms of framing like Wyatt is kind
of weird to see nebula do this with
their hand Skillshare is also super
affordable an annual subscription is
less than ten dollars a month
join more than 7 million creators
learning with Skillshare and a special
offer just for you guys
the first 500 of our subscribers to use
a link in the description below will get
a 2 month free trial so it's definitely
worth trying out just go to sk l dot sh
/ new rockstars 10 or click on the link
in the description ok let's get back to
that shot of the hand look closely at
Starks shoulder now the trailer opened
with lots of shots of sad Stark and the
blue tinted ship interior but remember
Stark was also wearing a tank top in
this shot his sleeves now yes infinity
war ended with him and nebula on Titan
and remember stark wore that zip up but
I don't know the material is a bit
different and I don't see a hooded part
or any trace of Peter Parker's dust
there does appear some kind of buckle
and strap maybe it's part of the harness
in the flight seat but it also looks a
bit like another buckle and strap that
we've seen the ones on catsuit now the
chin in the background is hard to make
out but whoever this is appears to have
just the amount of 5 o'clock shadow that
Stark has grown at this point but also
one that cap could have grown like two
minutes after shaving because man look I
should say that it don't really have any
firm inside knowledge from Marvel on
what exactly will happen in these movies
I'm just a nerd who he's into everything
but my god has been telling me that cap
will be the most likely one to die in
endgame it's too early to say exactly
how maybe some of that timeline Medlin
will allow him to swap places with Tony
Stark for cap to be the one to go off on
the cue ship to Titan not stark and cap
to replay the fight with Thanos and
cap to lose against Thanos leaving
nebula and cap stranded on Titan and
adrift on the Benatar maybe we'll see a
parallel moment to caps final moment the
cockpit of the Valkyrie soaring into the
abyss nebulas gesture here could be a
sign of these two heroes embracing
faiths having made peace with the foes
of the past nebula with Gamora and kat
with stark my question for you is should
Kimura resurrector should she stay dead
comment down below follow us and
subscribe to this channel and subscribe
to our new podcast where ever you listen
to podcasts and I'm launching a live
comedy show called darkest timeline
comedy so if you live in the LA area
come see me some buds from this channel
and some hilarious comedian friends do a
bunch of wild nerdy bits this Friday
February 1st and every first Friday
thereafter at Acme comedy in North
Hollywood thanks for watching and look
for the skeptics out there you're right
maybe it is just Stark in the chair
maybe it's a chair harness it's not
about cool but come on we have less than
three months to in-game and I've only
hit like a dozen of the 14 million 605
different possible futures that Doctor
Strange saw the good news is I only have
to be right once
[Music]